joining us right here on the show is one
of our favorite guests from the
worldwide leader in sports in the monday
night football booth
and one of the best voices talking
football on tv
is louis riddick back here on the show
how are you sir you're doing good man
how are you
i'm better for talking to you you always
make me smarter i enjoy our chats i say
that right
up front yeah i hope so well
i don't know about all average i love it
well you know one of my favorite talks
man
one of my favorite coaching cliches is i
don't have a crystal ball which means
you don't either
but how do you see the next six weeks in
the packers
aaron rodgers saga playing out louis
yeah i think i think aaron's going to be
doing a whole lot of what he was doing
just the other day
which is hanging out maybe having a you
know maybe making a few statements now
and then to some of his buddies in uh
in media playing some golf and the
packers better be doing exactly what
they're doing right now which is trying
to figure out how to make sure jordan
love is ready to go because
where's the more this goes the more i
could i just uh
i see that the pat the packers have kind
of dipped into the
petty pool as i like to say like they
want to go back and forth and have these
you know and mark murphy in particular i
shouldn't say the packers this really
just seems like mark murphy issue
wants to make these comments about aaron
aaron's not going to sit back and take
that lightly so he's going to make
as many comments as he needs to in
retaliation it just seems like
a a situation that's going nowhere fast
and i think getting all the way back to
the why
why we're even here in the first place i
think it's because of this kind of thing
that we're seeing playing out right now
which is a
failure to communicate a breakdown in a
relationship
it's really not it doesn't seem to be
any more simple i mean any more
complicated than that
it doesn't shock me i've seen it happen
before
in my time both as a player and in front
office
when communication breaks down
especially when you're talking about
star players man
that's just not a good recipe for for uh
for healthy relationships in today's day
and age because players are demanding
more and more
player empowerment has become the norm
it's not the exception anymore
especially with the top upper echelon
players and it's going to be that way
across all sports
football couldn't avoid it they just
couldn't i mean all we do
in our profession now is talk about how
the game is better
and it's better for us to talk about
when quarterbacks are at the center or
the centerpiece of the discussion
well here you have one who's a lock to
be a hall of famer
and you've got someone at the highest
levels of an organization
getting into like a petty little like
fight with him
well i shouldn't say a petty fight
because this is a big time fight but
someone who right now can't seem to kind
of manage a
a communication breakdown in an
adult-like manner and that's just uh
that's disappointing but it's going to
stay in the news we're going to continue
to talk about it but it's going nowhere
fast well the question is
the question is if the communication
from green bay at some point has been
and
i'm sure we can agree that it has been
the question has been posed what do you
want
what do you want and the question the
answer that might come back
is something that the packers can't
literally or figuratively give the
literally thing is turn back time they
can't do that
we can't we can't get into the football
delorean and set the time and date for
the 2020 nfl draft can't do that
um also can't get back in the delorean
set
the time for uh this past winter when
potentially if this did in fact happen
that the packers did put a contract on
the table for aaron
to sign uh as an extension but did not
give the terms and the dollars that
would force them to make a move with
jordan love
after rogers is done with the gig can't
go back into delorean and do that if
that pissed off rogers either can't go
back in the delorean and fix the jake
kumaro situation can't do that but so so
and and they're not going to fire gouda
kunst if that is in fact what rogers
wants they're not going to do that
what so what what what is it like what
what
what is it i think what is it i think
the only thing that i think inevitably
what's going to happen here is he just
he's not going to be there
he's just not and i don't think you know
i don't necessarily think he wants to
get in and i like that i mean i don't
think he wants to get into delorean that
being aaron i think sometimes rich it
just gets personal
it just gets to the point where you just
say with someone or something
i'm done with it i'm done there's
nothing i don't want to talk about it
anymore i don't
because quite honestly while this was
while it was happening while the
breakdowns were
happening you didn't want to talk you
made your bets
you forecasted you forecasted the future
in a way that obviously turned out to be
wrong and in this case they thought
aaron was turning down hill after the
2019 seas
they thought that he had already crested
the mountaintop and it was all downhill
after that
and he has said many times that
he threw a monkey wrench into their
plans with the 2020 season that he had
he just did
he screwed up the whole timetable for
them they thought they could get another
year
out of him and then they would be able
to usher in the jordan love era
and it would be nice and smooth and they
would control it
and he threw and he messed it all up for
him and you know a guy like that
he doesn't want anybody controlling
anything he'll tell you when he's done
he'll tell you when it's ready
when it's time to move on he'll tell you
when the relationship is over that's
just how he's wired
i don't have any problem with that i
mean i get it you know i've always said
look egos don't bother me man
everybody at this level at the highest
levels or whatever you're doing has the
egos
but they had a different agenda than he
does that's the problem
it's agendas that that blow this kind of
thing up
and i think he is this going to ride
this thing out he's going to lose a mon
a lot of money and the packers don't
have to do anything
if you want to look at it from their
standpoint they don't have to do
anything but get their team ready
the inflection points are when the
season starts and then the trade
deadline and then after that
it's the draft next year those are the
those are the three key inflection
points that aaron is staring at right
now
so what what what about rogers because
again
the other thing that packers aren't
going to do is trade him now and allow
allow rogers to improve for the team
that acquires him the draft choice that
the packers will have to accept
right now in a trade they're not going
to do that either right so
but if we wave to one and just said you
know the packers decided to say screw it
this is just not worth it it's not worth
it he's a complicated fellow let's give
the complicated fellow what he wants
what team would actually provide rogers
with the 2021
lightning in a bottle that brady enjoyed
that might have also added to the ogida
to this mix i i really do think based on
you know the the stuff that you hear
when you put your ear to the ground that
maybe maybe denver could do that just
think of the weaponry that they have the
improvements they made on the offensive
line the people
you know who they have running the
football and then the weaponry they have
on the perimeter
along with a defensive minded head coach
who can scheme it up and play top 10
defense
on a consistent basis in coach fangio
and you have a gm
right now who clearly from all
indications
is very interested in what's going on
with aaron and see and
is very interested in talking if the
packers really do want to talk
and why i mean why wouldn't i mean
that's a that's a legacy type of
franchise out there that's one of those
pillar type of franchises
that has been a destination spot for
many players for a long time
obviously they don't have the same they
don't come with the same cash as they
have in the past
because they haven't had the same
success on the field but the denver
broncos look that that's the team that
makes you sit up and go as a player
hey this is one of those one of those
franchises that demands respect that has
my respect that i
i need to really investigate and look at
here as
being a place that i would want to go to
if you're a guy like aaron rodgers
especially again
considering what he would have to work
with out there and he could make
all the difference in the world with
that young receiving coordinate young
nucleus especially on offensive side
i think that's exactly what they need i
like him monday night football's lewis
reddick here on the rich eisen show
ron rivera said today that ryan
fitzpatrick who knows
he could be the starter here for uh for
a bit
he he used the words for a while he
could be the guy here for a while
do you think we have an opportunity with
the way that that team is
molded on defense and the weapons that
they do have
um that he that that uh you know
that he could actually have a late
career renaissance similar to uh
what we're seeing elsewhere in sports he
mentioned obviously brady
and rivera mentioned brady and phil and
you know obviously rich gannon could be
another one right from
back in the day i think it's with ryan
it's never about
can he give you certain snapshots of
greatness and he's done that it's the
consistency and look
consistency of performance as you know
is the difference between being a
starter and a backup
the difference between being a starter
and a superstar hall of famer
is can you maintain that level of
performance over and over and over
year after year after year ryan can do
it for
five six games which really is the
quintessential definition of
a backup if you were to read a nfl
scouting menu manual
a guy who can fill in for four or five
games holds down the fort until the
regular starter comes back
and he'll probably win you three or four
games three of those four games keep you
above 500 in the time that he needs to
play so for ron to say look he could be
our starter for a while while he hasn't
proven he can do that
at any of the stops he's been at in his
career that being said
i think washington's the favorite in the
east easily
to me and people go you're crazy it's
got to be deck look it's dag and it's
zeke and it's the weapons there
blah blah blah look one through 52
i don't have any issues with the
redskins roster the issue if
you want to call it an issue is can ryan
sustain performance well enough to where
there are 10 win 11 win football team
because if they can get that out of him
where he doesn't cost them games
at the very least he doesn't cost them
games washington
is a problem because they are built
to win early middle
late season and be able to win in the
postseason
because of how they're strong up front
they're strong down the middle
they've added weaponry on the outside
that now can beat you
with big plays and or a ball control
type of offense
and you know their front four up on
defense will come and hunt your
quarterback down if they have a lead
and they're building up the secondary to
where it looks much better as well now
especially with the addition of william
jackson and free agency in the two
minutes
in washington's for real oh yeah i agree
with you and the two minutes that i i
have left here
um it's not the passing game
coordinator's job to announce a starting
quarterback but what'd you make of brian
schottenheimer in jacksonville's
comments that it's too early
it's too early to name a starting
quarterback in jacksonville i don't
i don't know why coaches do that kind of
crap man
i really don't like like
i'd love to know what urban said to him
like either before he went out there
to talk to the media or after i'd love
to know we can like what's wrong with
you
i mean what do you mean this isn't a
competition i came
urban came back to the nfl to coach this
guy he came back to the nfl because this
guy would be available
not because gardner minshew would be
there
to beat them out to beat him out or give
gardner a shot
i mean you know what that's what i'm
saying that's what that's what gets
media people salty and testy and then
all of a sudden they now they want to
start poking at you
because it's like stop bsing me man
don't don't do that that's insulting me
as a professional and it's making you
look dumb by doing that and i like brian
but hey i don't know maybe he was told
to say that i hope not
i don't know so again it's funny it's
not it's not a wide-open spot for for me
now i got to see if if it's a wide-open
spot that mince you could take now i
definitely want to see them on hard
knocks
no i definitely want to see it you know
no doubt yeah i mean that's
just you know coach that's the very
definition of coach speak that we don't
need man
louis thanks for the time appreciate it
have a good summer let's chat uh let's
chat dress before training camp let's do
it
no question thanks richard you got it
that's louis riddick at
l riddick espn i follow me as a must
follow fantastic
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here